[Music]
now it's official
netflix is producing its own assassin's
creed life action series for netflix
according to an official press release
of the streaming giant the cooperation
with game developer ubisoft has
only just begun therefore you can't
expect too much information about the
cast and the story yet
what is certain however is that the live
action series will only be the beginning
of a much larger universe
it's also clear that after the failed
assassin's creed movie from 2016
there will be no more efforts regarding
a film as netflix also announced on
twitter
the two ubisoft producers jason altman
and danielle kroenig are involved so far
much more interesting is the choice of
the showrunner of season 1
because similar to the success for
project the witcher they want to
convince the very critical gaming
community
right from the start the next release of
the franchise which comprises 11 main
games is
assassin's creed valhalla but it is not
yet possible to estimate when this
series will be released
[Music]
you